carl is
has been working now for a long time on
something he calls universal
intelligence systems
and this is this is interesting talk i
didn't realize this until i was putting
things together
uh
for the for the class today but what
he's really doing is he's forecasting
what the state of the world will look
like in 2030
based on what he knows today and what he
suspects is happening and uh with that i
think uh i'll let him explain what he's
doing and he will uh
and we can ask him questions
fantastic yeah fantastic fantastic
dennis thank you very much okay and uh
so yes the topic is universal
intelligence systems by 2030
and 2030 is not very far away i mean
it's far enough away that you can do
substantial amount of development the
big projects have been done in that
period of time in particular project
apollo
which completely revolutionized the
world
and the many of us and some of us in
silicon valley suspect that this is the
next one okay
and so i'm going to talk about you know
what it is what the technology is and
what the implications are
and um there are companies like
apple
and facebook and microsoft that are
investing billions of dollars in this
technology
so uh you can bet against them if you
want
but the suspicion is they they expect
because of this investment they have to
get money back they have to get return
on investment they suspect that this
will be a bigger revolution
than the smartphones by far
have much more impact on our lives will
really change our lives completely
now since it hasn't happened yet you
can't be certain about exactly how it's
going to happen or exactly when it's
going to happen
but people are making very large
investments
and a big part of that has to do with
these uh electronic glasses
the electronic glasses are
extraordinarily difficult to make
uh they
they are they they will be when they if
they come out soon if they come out they
will be the most technologically
advanced products on the planet bar none
more complicated and more sophisticated
than anything else
so i am the carl hewitt here and john
perry is busy working on trying to join
us
uh
as you heard
and so and if you want to learn more
about what i'll be talking about here
you go to my you go to my blog which is
on blogspot
and there it has links to a whole bunch
of articles and other videos
so with that beginning
let us take a look at what we have
so the question is what are universal
intelligent systems well universal says
they're going to be everywhere
and that's based on the premise that the
electronic glasses will be everywhere
and used for everything they're already
starting to be used extensively in
industry
and so i needed to take an example i had
to talk i can't just talk about it in
complete vagueness i need an example
so the example that i picked was
policing
and the the electronic glasses will
revolutionize policing
and this is just a poor innocent police
officer
wearing sunglasses and she's got a
little electronic doohickey hanging out
i don't even see that behind but that's
what we think this is going to look like
okay these electronic glasses are going
to look like so what will they do for
the police officers well when a police
officer is going around whenever a
police officer sees somebody the glasses
will instantly tell them who they are
and if they have a police record it will
instantly
say what that police record is
and yeah otherwise it'll bring up their
social media whatever whatever whatever
that's useful to the police officer as
they're going around okay
and the glasses will provide situational
awareness you can't see them here but
actually in the real electronic glasses
they have cameras in the back of it in
the back frames
so the electronic glasses will be
watching the officers back off policing
is a very difficult and dangerous
activity right
and now the police will have somebody
watching their back all the time
and they will and and they also in terms
of situational awareness the police
often work together in squads when
they're going after a suspect
and so one police officer will be able
to see what the other police officers
are seeing on their glasses
so the glasses are really something they
will revolutionize policing they'll also
have another effect
namely they will
provide police accountability the police
will now become completely accountable
for everything they do they hear they
say
because it'll all be recorded by the
glasses and sent up to police central
so this is going to be a big deal in
terms of policing
so to make these glasses useful
it's it's just like our cell phones
they're just bricks without the software
to make them useful
somehow these the system has to in real
time
robustly integrate information under
contention so here we have another
innocent police officer wearing what
look like very dark glasses so this is
the
pretty good idea what they're going to
look at
but
collecting all this information of all
these different kinds right you get all
sorts of information and misinformation
all has to be integrated
and the intelligence system will always
be running into edge cases
and they'll be contingencies always
happen it's not going to be as simple
clean consistent mathematical theory
that is not possible
and so for a policeman
like you know suppose this was a
policeman on january 6 standing outside
the capitol
this is actually a capital policeman
you have evidence for both is it safe or
is it dangerous well
uh
hopefully it'll be safe but on the other
hand this the mob that's approaching the
the capitol building doesn't look too
good does it right on the other hand the
whole bunch of us police here
and what could possibly go wrong so is
it dangerous well there's evidence both
ways
and the intelligence systems have to
integrate this information which is not
easy
so how do they do that
the way we'll do that is
the intelligent system itself yeah i
think that was a slide about
revolutionizing policing okay i won't
repeat everything i've said this is just
reiterates the points
about personal identity identification
situational awareness watching the
officers back
seeing what the other officers have seen
and providing police accountability so
now
this information system has a very tough
time of it
because
it's always running into edge cases
contingencies are always arising and so
we took the case of this capital
policeman
capitol police officer
is it safe or not
standing there on january 6th
mixed messages right
well the intelligence the police have
gotten so far hasn't been so good
on the other hand nobody seems worried
right
okay
so
so the proposal for how these
intelligence systems are going to work
is they're going to work the same way
scientific communities work use
scientific processes there are the
internal discourse
and so inside the intelligent system
it's going to be debating inside itself
is it safe or is it dangerous what's the
evidence that it's safe right well we
got a lot of policemen here right we've
got barriers up so it's safe what's the
evidence that's dangerous
well the president of the united states
has just ordered them to come to the
capitol hmm
okay we got mixed messages here and you
always have mixed messages
so
the intelligence system will make use of
internal discourse right
so here we have situation one we're
staying at the capitol right
and uh
and uh and and we have a message here
with a certain providence saying that
situation one is a safe situation
and then that turns into
and this is this is an active kind of
thing
turns into a declarative kind of thing
situation one is a safe situation as a
result of this and so what you what the
in the intelligence system is doing is
it's constructing an active ontology
of what it what's going on in the world
and it's not consistent but it compiles
everything goes into the active ontology
okay
and um
one of the important things that's
different from the current system you
have on your cell phones
is
it's going to make use of causal
understanding so it's not one of these
purely associative
neural net systems
that's working on the basis of
correlations these are systems have to
go beyond correlations
and so for example it knows that you
know it has here we have situation one
situation one is a safe situation
because we've got a lot of police here
in the capital
and it's a dangerous situation because
the president has just ordered all these
people to go to the capitol right
now
the abstract meeting comes in is the
system knows a
safe situation is not a dangerous
situation
that is abstract knowledge that is
causal knowledge that's necessary for
the operation of the intelligence system
and
let's see
so
just a second here
that there's a place we're gonna have i
was gonna have some discussion with john
perry but john perry hasn't arrived on
the scene yet so we'll have the
discussion a little bit later and you
guys will be able to join in too
okay and so
these intelligence systems will go far
beyond our current
smartphones in two very important
respects one is they'll be
self-informative and the other is it
will facilitate discourse with humans
i'm about to explain both of those
so here we have self-informative
these systems will have a causal
understanding of their own capabilities
and limitations
okay
they will know a lot about how they work
what they can do and they what they
can't do and since this is all machinery
inside the intelligence system they can
have a causal understanding of that
machinery okay and this goes way beyond
anything you can do with correlations
with neural networks
the other thing is
that these systems will be involved
intensely involved with discourse with
humans with other humans right
and this for the for example the
the the uh the the uh the uh
the electronic glasses of the uh of each
one of these police will be talking
electronic glasses of the other police
and these police will be able to talk to
each other through their electronic
glasses
and the glasses will be able to talk to
them through bone conduction microphones
and why bone conduction on bone
conduction microphones other people
particularly criminals will not be able
to
eavesdrop on what the intelligence
system is saying to the police officer
and
the
electronic glasses of a police officer
will talk to the police officer okay and
and for example they might say
you know i notice your drew you know
says the glasses say i know say to the
police officer through the bone
conduction uh uh headphones it'll say to
the police officer
you know i noticed you've been drooping
a little bit here right eyes are getting
a little bit heavy right
you look you think you're tired do you
think he might need a break
so that's what the the the electronic
glasses will say to the police officer
trying to help them out as best they can
so
it's going to come to pass we think that
by 2030
that a police that the eyeglasses the
electronic glasses will be as important
to a police officer as their pistol is
for them now they won't be able to cope
you know with doing policing anymore
without their electronic glasses then
they would would be able to without
their their weapons their defense
weapons
so that is the deal
and does any of you guys have any
questions at this point about the nature
of the beast
that's coming by 2030
yes
um i have a question that maybe this is
like too in-depth with the engineering
but i'm just curious how it will
so you say here like writing and
animations like so is this gonna
integrate with the where's eyesight so
like they're seeing some image and it
like
can overlay let you know the way you
would like imagine it in a spy movie or
something is it like this exactly right
like those science fiction movies that
it will put up text
and pictures right in front of your eyes
you're able to read things you'll be
able to read when you when you meet we
meet somebody on the street if they're
criminal it will put up right in front
of your eyes their rap sheet
how will that work with like the depth
of your vision i'm just so curious about
like
how you will be able to
look at something far away and see
something that's like right in front of
your eyes you know
you've identified a very serious
technical problem that facebook and and
apple are putting zillions of dollars
into
and one of the ways that it's proposed
for them to do that
is to have the electronic glasses using
lasers directly right on your retina
with very low power right okay that's a
technology developed by bosch and there
are motorcycle glasses that that do that
today in other words this state they're
already motorcycle glasses where you
when you drive around it puts up
directions for you right that's built
into your hem it puts up directions says
turn right at the next intersection
right because it knows what your
itinerary is puts up a little sign there
and it'll say warning construction ahead
and it'll say warning i see road ahead
it'll write that right there in front of
your eyes very cool yep
excellent question
thank you
okay
so now
let's go up one level and ask the
question what difference
could universal intelligence systems
make
and
it's going to change everything and
what's the the companies think that
by 2030 there will be billions of
electronic
glasses in use they'll be used in the
military they'll be used in health
education government families
transportation the whole not they'll be
you know
if persons walking down the street right
and they don't see that there's a curb
coming out the glasses will warm them
about to step off the curb and by the
way it'll warn them about the on
oncoming car that's coming from the
right another reason yeah be careful
when you step on the curb but in the
meanwhile wait for this car
so
so so that that's that's going to be a
really big
deal
and
now there are two ways to make these
intelligent systems there's a
totalitarian top-down way
and a representarian bottom-up way
they're going to be two kinds of these
systems two big ecosystems
just like you know for example the the
internet in some countries is now cut
off from the internet in other countries
some countries run their internet as a
closed system with censorship right well
they're going to be two ways to do
these intelligence systems
the totalitarian identity
alternative is truly terrifying
because because these classes very these
glasses are even more controlling
than the kinds of little and narrow
areas that are run inside facebook so
little little thought control bubbles
right
they they really control what you see
and what you hear and they can hear
everything you say
so they so that so in a totalitarian
system these things are the basis for
directed thought control
and the idea is to go way beyond
uh brave new world if you've read that
novel or 1984
and to prevent prohibitive thoughts
instead of just censoring them when
you're censoring them it's already too
late they've already had the prohibited
thought so the idea of these systems is
to prevent prevent prevent
those kinds of thoughts
and the other way is the representative
representation alternative which is to
support representative government and
civil liberties so those are the two big
ways these systems will be constructed
so what do you think of that
is that terrifying or not
it is i'm curious like with the
prevention of thought how would that
integrate with
thought is it
it's it's to subtly guide you away so
you don't have you don't have
information
you know it's though but if if there was
a massacre someplace or the government
requests somebody someplace you won't be
able to find that information anywhere
okay on the on on your on your internet
or your database etc it's just not there
so the basis for those kinds of of
thoughts it just just won't be there
okay
now there's a crucial technical
requirement for for both kinds of the
system they have to be resilient against
direct cyber attack
in in in in in a representarian way okay
you don't want the government spying on
you without a warrant and you want to
have you you get to have some privacy
the idea of you you the king can't enter
your home without a
without a warrant right
uh and but it's also very important in a
totalitarian country for the electronic
glasses to be resilient against cyber
attack
because if you're the dictator of a
foreign country and you're using this
electronic glasses for everything if a
foreign intelligence agency can break
into your electronic glasses that's no
good right
so even in a totalitarian country they
need very good protection
resilience against direct cyber attack
which which we don't have today it's
just too easy to break in
so
currently
you being computer scientists you guys
will know that we currently use the von
neumann architecture which is a kind of
thing was a process of doing reading and
writing to memory and that's inherently
insecure
so we need to move to a new abstraction
for computing
called the actors abstraction and these
these things
are inherently secure right
no but nobody can read what's going on
inside an actor nobody can write into
what's going on inside an actor all you
do is send the actor a message so they
are inherently secure
and these things have become practical
because big companies like
apple and microsoft okay have frameworks
in which you can write large-scale
applications
and there are smaller companies but very
important companies like airline
solutions and like ben okay that have
constructed a whole large-scale
abstraction whole large-scale
applications using actors so it's not
just a theory theoretical importance
it's also of extreme practical
importance
now the deal is
one actor is no actor
you have any of you heard of the famous
uh biologist eo wilson who unfortunately
just died
he studied ants
and his slogan was one ant is no ant
right
one ant makes no sense whatsoever right
it really doesn't a standalone ant is a
dead irrelevant ant
same thing is true of actors actors come
in the billions
so
actors come in the billions so
the way that they do their billions is
so so actors are arranged in citadels
where you have billions of them for
example your house will be a citadel
and in the citadel of the various pieces
of equipment like you've got your home
router which is this thing you got your
car you've got your glasses you've got
your screens right and they all work
closely together as in
in an integrated way
to protect your sensitive information
this is like the idea of your house now
right the citadel is your electronic
house it's the thing that protects your
sensitive information
and then you deal and then you deal with
the outside data centers right over the
internet right at a kind of arms length
way
and these things these things have a
business model everything on the
internet has to have a business model or
won't survive
and the idea of the business model is
the way the citadel
raises money for itself
is that it charges
uh it charges referral fees to merchants
and brokers for the things that the
first people in the house want to buy to
the same way that google and facebook
make their money now it's the same thing
that will float the citadels
okay so
using actors and citadels and the actors
enable you to prove specifications using
event induction
that's the thing that's going to provide
the the requisite level of resilience
without which the glasses will not be
safe to use because we will become so
dependent on the glasses then unless you
have a
very high resilience against cyber
attacks it just becomes completely
impossible
either in a totalitarian
country or in a representarian country
so both sides will need this cyber
resilience
and
we are now engaged in a pacing race okay
between the totalitarian approach toward
intelligence systems
and the representarian approach
and the representarian approach is in a
pacing race for the survival
of representative government and civil
liberties that's where we stand
today
and so
the proposal is to do an apollo scale
project liftoff
this just just as kennedy proposed a
quote apollo scale project to do space
to be to rockets and get into space
right
we now have to do that for intelligent
systems if we're going to keep up
and again if you want to learn more
about this you can go to articles and
and videos
at my
at my uh
on my on my blog
okay
so that is the basic size of the thing
any overall questions
about
what what the enterprise is because what
we are is what difference could
universal intelligence make the
individuals and families
communities to policing organizations
like police and to nations
i did have a question so how would you
suggest
moving towards representative systems
over authoritarian systems like how do
you stop
an authoritarian system from being built
and keep it in
the other direction that's a good
question and the answer is that we
cannot see keep the authoritarian cells
built it's actually being built in a
country on the other side of the ocean
right
and they're probably ahead of us
so the only thing you can do but the
russians got ahead of us right and in
space right they got ahead of us right
but we caught up and passed them
but we couldn't keep their system from
being built all we could do was build a
better one and we built a better one
here in silicon valley by inventing
silicon chips right and building massive
systems lockheed grumman
which led the creation of google and
facebook
and and and microsoft those companies
and our systems were better than their
systems
and the united states systems took over
the world
but excellent question
just because we've done it before
doesn't necessarily mean we'll do it
again we have a big heavy lift ahead of
us
but good question
other questions
i'm curious about um
what you think the implications are for
like
culture and society because i mean it's
one thing if you have
people like police officers being
held fully accountable that like even
that would completely potentially change
that
field of work um
and if this
technology becomes
common for normal people to just be
wearing around like to have a full
playback of every conversation and
everything i mean that would be
kind of
that would just change everything you
know um
at least i'm just curious for your
thoughts on that that's a very good
question for example should the glasses
right should the glasses have a little
red light that comes on when they're
recording well they're going to be
recording all the time so the red light
will always be on so yes so this this is
already we have a problem that people go
around you know with this little
square piece of classic in front of
their face all the time they even doing
it dinner when they're talking to their
family right
and it has really changed social
relationships not necessarily for the
better and the glasses pose ex these
challenges except they become much more
extreme
the huge social challenges
this really stands to transform society
work and society in a fundamental way
you think that you think it's bad now
the people addicted their cell phones i
mean the people that addicted the
glasses will just be completely
ridiculous they'll never take them off
and the fact that people will sleep with
them on because they can provide people
to provide them you know with with
mantras and beautiful visions while
they're sleeping so
that will become a thing a medical issue
right people sleeping with their glasses
in fact they'll probably be special
glasses designed for people while
they're sleeping whoopee
so yeah this is going to be huge it's
good it's going to be transformative for
better and for worse at the same time
you know it'll really make a whole
society more efficient and will prevent
a huge number of accidents it will it
would it will enable the elderly right
to to live by themselves for much longer
than they can now it'll prevent
accidents right
it'll give you good advice you know when
you look at that ice cream cone it says
yeah that's okay but you know think of
the sugar and think of the crash after
you come down from eating that damn
thing
[Laughter]
so it's got to be it's going to be huge
okay so i remember google glass
was like kind of the next big thing a
few years ago and it didn't seem to take
off so was that mostly due to a
technical challenge a like
adoption challenge
or
like a software problem yeah well it's
two things it's a hardware and a
software i can remember the motorola
phone it was as big as a brick right and
it talked to satellites maybe it came
before your time and it was going to be
the next big thing and the answer is the
technology wasn't that that wasn't the
device it was the thing that could fit
in your pocket not the big brick right
they held up your your head right
and then you got to get the software
right so there are a whole bunch of
things i was in japan and i was using
things that look very much like our cell
phones in japan
10 years before the iphone came out
but they didn't have the software and
they had this little chunky piece of
plastic that you had to use to write
your your kana on the screen right
so the answer is yes the road to success
is paved with many failures
[Laughter]
and the challenge is to be to be the
first one to get the minimal viable
product that sells millions and steve
job was a genius at that with the ipod
right
the mac the iphone he was a g he wasn't
first okay but he was the first there
with a mass market
and that's what facebook and google
they're staring at each other across you
know across across the small distance
between them each thinking hmm who's
gonna do it
[Laughter]
okay so that's the situation there i
think good question
anything else
well
that was the discussion period
now science works in mysterious ways
things that are done a long time ago by
the people you may
have heard about like fraga
and church and turin
and wittgenstein
right
all those people thought they were doing
philosophy and they thought they were
doing mathematics
and now
you know the the work has to be
transformed all all that good where
we're going to build on with the stuff
that they did but it has to be
transformed
because we have to prevent these cyber
attacks
and those old mathematical
paradoxes that people thought were jokes
right
can be used by cyber attackers because
we're using mathematical foundations and
if they can use one of those paradoxes
to break in we're toast
so but anyway so here we are here we are
here we are taking a slight diversion
into the history of this thing about how
science works illustrating how science
works
and
science makes connections between very
strange things right
uh it's it's you do do some fundamental
science in one area and all of a sudden
it comes in a practical way it impacts
something else like einstein does the
general theory of relativity
to try to deal with with with with some
fundamental problems right
and our gps system depends on
corrections that are made on the basis
of general
who relativity
who would have thought that right
and and church did his fundamental work
on computation right
and he was amazed when people when when
the people came and told him you know
that lambda council you invented back in
we're actually using that in computers
and church said well you know
i had a student okay named alan turing
who was interested in computers
right so so you never know when
connections are going to be made
right
and mathematics being the purest form of
abstraction
has the greatest chance to connect
together very disparate things because
it is so pure and so abstract there
might be an area practical area of
application over in one place that gets
connected with a practical area of over
another place using
mathematics so that's actually happened
here in terms of
of uh defense against cyber attacks
because there was a guy named girdle
kurt girdle who 1931
came up with a proposed solution to a
fundamental mathematical problem which
had been posed by hilbert namely is
every mathematical proposition decidable
true or false in other words can
mathematics become complete
can you have a mathematical theory that
for every proposition it'll either prove
it or disprove it so it'll be able to
decide
for every proposition no matter how hard
right could there be such a thing
and girl came up with this proposition
called i'm unprovable so you can go look
at the red right then sentences says i'm
unprovable you can't prove me right
and good old i'm unprovable well of
course if you could prove him by his
statement i'm unprovable that he'd be
unprovable on the other hand
if you if you could show that he's
disprovable then he'd be provable
so there's a way
to try to deal with that in a very
limited theories
but it turns out in powerful theories
which we have now
i i'm approval enables a cyber attack on
our fundamental theory we can't have
that
so we figured out a way using types you
may have seen types in your programming
languages
some programming languages have types
using types we can show that the
proposition i'm unprovable does not
exist which is a very good thing
because if it did exist it would be a
torpedo on which would that would enable
cyber attacks
so there's another one which is famous
which is church's paradox
alonzo church one of the greatest
logicians of all time the inventor of
the line of calculus which is the basis
the programming language lisp
and it was also used the ideas were used
in programming languages like algol
and uh and uh a whole bunch of other
programming languages that we use now
so
church was thinking about things
and he he thought about you know things
going back to to to
euclid and he thought about that and he
said well look there's this proposition
my theorems are innumerable
well
that proposition is deadly because it
results in a fundamental contradiction
in mathematical logic
and church wrote a paper in 1935 saying
that because of this proposition my
theorems are innumerable
mathematical logic is impossible
of course he does you know
nothing depended on that i mean the
church proceeded to do a whole bunch of
excellent work after that he just
ignored the problem he think look we'll
solve it later right
no no skin off our cat here because we
just we're philosophers we just do our
thing right that's an interesting
paradox no problem
but for us computer scientists
this is deadly
because you you you can be you can base
a cyber attack on this thing right this
is a hole in mathematics we have to we
have to fix every one of those things
so what you do is you fix up euclid a
little bit instead of saying see euclid
thought the theorems you begin with the
axioms
you apply the rules of inference
and but then you can mechanically
generate all of all the theorems that
was euclid's idea
well we can't live with that
so we change the definition of what a
theorem is
and we say the solution which is right
here a theorem is a proposition whose
proof can be algorithmically checked for
correctness
and that's what we care about right
whether or not it has a correct proof
that we can check for correctness we
don't nobody's planning on enumerating
all the theorems all infinitely many of
them right nobody's planning on doing
that right so we get rid of that thing
and now
we can
self-correct
so we have another proposition and this
is incredibly technical i don't expect
you to if you guess this down if you
want to under to do this you have to go
to my blog and read the article
it says my string theorems of an order
are innumerable
okay
and this thing is what
kurt gerdel was seeking and the thing
that destroyed hilbert's program for
mathematics
because this proposition my string
theorems of an order a numeral is not
provable
because of the diagonal argument the
church discovered in 1935
and it's not disprovable because this
proposition is actually true
in the model of our theory
so we can show
that there's no way to prove this
proposition and there's no way to
disprove it
so this is the way science works you
know every people had the intuition
that mathematics was uh mathematics was
incomplete that there were undecidable
propositions
girdle came up with a proposition
it was accepted okay as correct okay for
40 years
and then we found a problem with it
that's the way science works
okay
so that's the little diversion on
science here in the scientific science
the way science actually works anybody
have any questions about this a little
technical it's okay if you don't
but it's it's it's interesting how
science works
what was the issue with the enumeration
is it that there were just so many that
like technically it's innumerable that
it would just be too
costly to actually no no no
it's the the problem is that this
proposition this proposition you may be
familiar with cantor the cantor argument
that shows that that that
that the real numbers are not
innumerable
ah yeah okay
okay so so that shows it's impossible to
enumerate uh
the uh the natural numbers so if the
theorems were innumerable right
then it turns out you can run a very
similar diagonal argument to show that
they're not
you can create a proposition you thought
you'd enumerated all of them and now you
can construct a theorem that's not in
the list so they can't be innumerable
okay
that makes sense so you have to rethink
but good question
thank you
okay
so
let's talk about back doors this is
another thing about uh about
the cyber security system that we're in
a back door you know i have a very
general definition of a back door you
may have heard that you know
the people that can install back doors
in cell phones like there was this nso
group an israeli security group because
it was selling cyber attacks that
enabled back doors to be assigned to be
put in the in the in
and then they would sell it to
governments right
so they'd sell to the mexican government
and the mexican government would then
use it to spy on reporters who were
trying to report on the government
and they they'd sell it to to uh to
other governments which would would with
uh spies and and then there was that
there was there was khashoggi the famous
journalist right
they put a back door in his in his phone
right
so
that's the story what a back door is
and there's some very bad news with
respect to back doors namely
these things called
ultimate back doors this is a way to put
a back door in a device
so that
it's it's it's safe against direct cyber
attack and it involves cryptography
and uh
etc and keeping the billions of private
keys secret
but it means that a
authoritarian regime has a secure way to
put
a back door
in the in the in the electronic in the
electronic classes of every one of their
citizens
and foreign intelligence agencies won't
be able to exploit this back door the
government makes use of it to extract
all the information
but their worst fear is that some other
foreign intelligence agency could break
in and make use of the back door
and the answer is that these ultimate
back doors
are safe they're resilient against
direct cyber attack
this mechanism was actually you know and
i think might have been invented by the
central intelligence agency
for putting back doors in people that
they were spying on
but other people have all
caught on
so so so so that this means that you
know it really is possible for these
totalitarian regimes to put a back door
in every pair of eyeglasses
people are busy trying to read the slide
to see if they can possibly encompass
all this this exactly how they do that
so i just gave you the overview
so i'll leave the slide up and we'll see
if anybody has any questions about this
but this is very bad this is very bad
news
it means it really is possible for the
totalitarian regimes to do this
every pair of glasses
securely against foreign intelligence
agencies
and this occurs during manufacturing
yes it did in manufacturing right in
manufacturing each device has a
hardwared public key
it's not secret there's nothing secret
inside the glasses
but this hardware
but the but the government has the
private key for this public key has
billions of them one for each pair of
glasses
so what the government does is they send
the glasses right
a bootloader encrypted
en encrypted with the pop the private
key the glasses get it decrypt with a
public key so they know it must have
come from the government and that takes
over your glasses
so science works in various ways i mean
you invent something like nucle like
nuclear energy right like like uh silard
and fermi did right
and
used properly you know
nuclear energy could be the basis of
electric power that doesn't cause global
warming
it could save our planet
the same time nuclear energy is the
basis of bombs okay
that could kill us all now
there's enough nuclear energy enough
nuclear weapons on the planet now to
kill us all
easily
so
science cut can cut both ways
okay
so now we can go into a more technical
part of the talk in which i explain
how these actors and citadels actually
work
to provide cyber resilience and you have
to remember that
that both both systems both the
totalitarian system and the
representation system have to have
resilience against cyber attacks
in order to in in order to work
otherwise it won't work neither one will
work so both both sides are going to
have to do this
and
i can actually fix this thing
right here i can do this and i can do
that
and now i've fixed a typo small one okay
so
to do this these active systems we have
to go beyond the church touring paradigm
church and turing invented
a beautiful theory of computation which
is taught in all the undergraduate
courses at stanford everywhere else and
it's in the wikipedia it's in all the
encyclopedias
but it's obsolete
we have to it was we have to go beyond
that right
and to go beyond that we have a very
simple system here
which is a train system trains it has a
train controller an engine controller
and a door controller right
and you see the idea that church touring
paradigm
was that you had a man
sitting alone
who's given as much paper and pencil as
they need as they're going along they
can always get more paper and more
pencil
and they're following a recipe
and
if the recipe stops then they output the
answer on the piece of paper that was
their model of computation
well
this is not the model here we got these
train controllers engine control door
all operating you know
at the same time right
and they have to communicate with each
other
so
what do we do
well we have a train controller
and you see the issue for the train
controller
is that both the engine controller and
the door controller
might be trying to communicate with the
train controller at the same time
how can you do that
and the answer is that the train
controller has a region of mutual
exclusion
so
when one of them is trying to talk to it
it processes that little request that
little piece of work and then it goes
and processes the next piece of work
and it does that in a region of mutual
exclusion
so it just does one little piece of work
at a time
but it can be coming in from a whole
bunch of different sources
and so here we have the trade so the
train controller is getting all these
requests in from the outside world it's
getting all these these these these uh
responses back from the door controller
and the train control and the trip and
then from the door controller and the
train controller has to keep this all
organized
that's it that's the challenge
uh the new model of computation
how with all these things going on all
these trillions of things going on at
the same time how do you keep it
organized
so i won't read the code for this here
but uh it's available in the papers in
the blog if you want to go read the code
and so now
so this whole model of computation is
based on activities not states the
traditional model of computation is
based on a state
the word the world is in a given state
it goes chunky to the next global state
goes kachank
and the problem is states are static and
the world we live in is not
so um we have a fundamental principle
how do you prove things about these
these systems
and it uses in event induction
so you have some system here and we like
to prove something about all the events
in the system now you may have
in your in your in your computer science
courses
you have learned about mathematical
induction right you want to prove
something about all the integers if you
could prove that it's prove for zero and
if you can prove that it's true for i
then it's true for i plus one
then by golly it's true of all the
integers no matter how complicated the
property is
same thing here for these systems only
now we're doing it for systems
and so now we say well okay
the we we have an induction step that
says
for every incoming event for the system
has property p and if an internal event
has property p
then the immediate successors of e have
property p
well if you can prove
this inductive hypothesis
you get to conclude that every event of
the system has property p
and just like induction for natural
numbers is the fundamental principle for
proving properties about the integers
this is the foundation for proving the
specifications of our computer systems
highly technical all this but you guys
are engineers right
okay
so we have a specification
that
for a very reasonable specification for
this uh train controller
that it's never the case
that
the train the the for the train
controller that it has it recorded that
it's moving
while it has recorded that the door is
open
never happened
that's what we're going to prove
so when we first start off when we first
start off with the train controller
in the constructor for those of you who
know about object-oriented programming
like in java
we set is moving to false and we set is
open to false right
well we're good to start with because
it's not the case that we have both of
them being true right
and then we just have to maintain that
invariant whatever message that we
receive
coming in and going out right
we just have to maintain that
so
in maintaining it
uh
the train control has got its regions of
mutual exclusion
so what you have to
what you have to show
is if this specification that it's not
the case that it's both moving and open
if it's true when you come into the
region of mutual exclusion
then it's true when you leave the region
of mutual exclusion if you can show that
that's always the case
then we'll know that always the case
that we have our invariant our
specification it's not the case that
it's both moving and open at the same
time
okay
so there are two kinds of cyber attacks
that could go on
uh basically uh
here's the internal ones the train
controller can be attacked by the engine
controller the door controller
or
the uh
yeah i think there was a typo there
this internal see there's a typo here in
the slide this is the way science works
right it should be external
okay
and then i've got the wrong picture here
huh
well i i think what happened was i
duplicated the slide incorrectly okay
but anyway you have to be protected so i
can show the picture here
so this train controller has to be
protected against cyber attacks from the
outside communications coming in from
the outside
and also it has to be protected against
communications coming from the engine
controller and the door controller
i see that that's not in his head so he
i think he gets it
[Laughter]
so people so you see what we're up to
we're doing a giant inductive proof to
prove our specification
and when we do that
we get to
we get down here
so
here's the deal
we can prove the specifications for our
system we've got a nice computer system
we've got it deployed we can prove the
specifications
now what we can't prove
is anything about the physical train
itself
even though we proved our specifications
things can go wrong in the physical
world
the physical we can't prove that the
physical crane is not moving while the
door is open at 2 42 pm we can't prove
that we can prove internally that the
trained system thinks it's okay okay but
the real world can always do something
else
so that's just a fundamental fact about
the world
so do people have any questions
okay and then the train controller is
just an example
using this this method we can prove
things about operating systems
networking systems our graphics systems
our database systems they can all be
proved using this method but it is
intensely labor intensive right and
requires a large amount of mechanization
so this can be done in the next 10 years
it's necessary
for
intelligent systems because we become so
dependent on these glasses that we have
to have cyber resilience
so both sides have to do it
but it's extremely expensive
so it's going to take a large project to
do it this is a big challenge on both
sides
and that is i don't know how we're doing
on time here dennis
that was about the hour
i have a question for you about this uh
big project that you're pointing as out
as needed yeah can we use artificial
intelligence to do the work
uh not the kind that we can build in
this decade i mean we we can automate
like this all this proving
specifications right we we we can semi
automate it but it's going to take
a large number tens of thousands
of trained highly trained software
engineers who know about proof theory
and know about complicated languages and
know about operating systems and
networking systems
it's going to take tens of thousands of
highly trained
computer professionals to do this
we can automate part of it
with proof checkers
but the real work cannot be completely
automated in this decade i don't think
okay
all right
um any case we started a little late so
i think we could go a little bit further
where do you stand in your slides
well in the slides i stand
at the point where
i could talk
i could talk some more about actors but
it's so highly technical i don't think
it's worth it so i really think that at
this point we could really use john if
we could possibly have him to talk about
the philosophical
implications of what this means what was
the fundamental question that we asked
at the beginning right which which is
the overall overarching uh
uh question for the for the whole deal
which is uh
what difference
can will could universal intelligent
systems make
in our you know for the individuals what
difference would it make for students at
stanford
what difference will it make if you're
sitting in the classroom right and
you've got your glasses on
and the professor has their glasses on
so you don't really need the big screen
in front right that that kind of becomes
superfluous right
um
so the the professor could be collecting
your questions in real time from your
from your glasses right
and uh you can be sitting there voting
in real time as to how it's going
again real time feedback
and you can be you can you can be
dragging things in off the internet if
you ask the professor question they can
drag things into the internet off the
internet and send them to your glasses
so so there's a lot more there's a lot
more individuality in the classroom
it's not as monolithic and lockstep with
just one big display at the front
and it's also it also also doesn't have
people you know with their noses and
their phones
off distracted doing something else or
their noses in the laptop looking at
something else so that the potential for
a much more synergistic
collaborative classroom
would you like that
yeah well it sounds it sounds pretty
good i guess
yeah because he prepared he you know and
john and i prepared extensively john is
a very famous philosopher john is one of
the founders of csli which is a very
important resource at stanford
uh which way back in the early days when
i was doing the early work on whack
actors he was one of the founders of
csli we got both got funding from the
same place he got 15 million dollars we
didn't eat quite that much
and
that was the beginning you know of a
very important center at stanford
did
terrifically important work on on
linguistics
with dan flickinger and
emily bender and a whole bunch of other
people that's going to be an important
foundation for intelligent systems in
which
the current neural networks
will be only a very tiny small part of
the intelligent systems that we will
build in these
decades
it's basically the current neural nets
are good for signal processing and not
much else
a little bit of pattern recognition not
so we have a huge task in front of us in
terms of doing this stuff
and what we don't know is whether
a kind of representative
independent
companies can do it
or whether it takes a national project
like the apollo project you see the
companies couldn't compete with the
russians going into space the the
companies at the time the boeings
the uh the wright brothers whatever the
companies they had they just couldn't do
it
so in a totalitarian country the
dictator can order up a project like
this
and do it
whereas in a country like ours we have
to get organized we were late to the
scene we were not first into space the
russians were
we caught up but only when we did
project apollo
but
apollo paid for my education it was the
russian and the russians were what made
me into a scientist
they they orbited this little grapefruit
called sputnik that we went over our
house in el paso i would open the garage
and close the garage door every time it
went open
and that scared the people in washington
they decided
that they needed more scientists and
engineers and i was a junior in el paso
high right what chance do i have except
that they i do i did well on quizzes
so they sent me down to
junior overachievers school at texas a m
summer my junior year and i met people
right and uh i guess he'll tell me what
he wants me to do
okay john has appeared i was just i was
just singing your praises john i
explained how you know
thanks for all your efforts and for csl
i explained how you were found one of
the founders of csli and kind of been in
the business for a long time
and how we've been over how we've been
over the slides and that you had some
important comments and additions from a
philosophical point of view to add to
this
uh so here's some comments on what
you've heard from carl
so let me first say that carl is
brilliant
uh
he's a accomplished computer scientist
he's what i call an ai enthusiast
but
he doesn't like the term ai he prefers
intelligent systems
there's not
any issue
on which carl doesn't have an opinion
even the name of the profession he's in
but anyway i'll continue to use the term
ai for communicative purposes while
bowing to his
no doubt correct opinion that
intelligent systems is better
so he's an enthusiast
he's willing to think of a
dark side of all good things innovations
uh lead to
uh so so carl is a computer science and
ai enthusiast but unlike many he's
willing to think of the dark side that
all these wonderful innovations can lead
to
i i am what i would call a computer
science and a.i grouch
who can be persuaded of some things that
come from them
uh but whose mind is more naturally
drawn to the problems they can create
so so so with the glasses carl first
thinks of all the wonderful things they
could do if we had these super glasses
and then says of course there might be
some problems like it
might help the chinese take over the
world
and so forth and so on
but i immediately think of the problems
and say
why are we funding this research anyway
as i say i'm a grouch
now in in general
we can agree that decisions are improved
by relevant access to relevant
information
and here like most people use
ambiguously we usually information
suggests something that's true and
factual
but
for for reasons
nobody understands except maybe dan
flickinger uh we now use information
for misinformation disinformation and
information to default this information
but no you know it just works
carl points out some of the tragedies
that have involved police
faced with weapons and what or thinking
they're faced with weapons and what they
take to be an urgent situation
in the in the context of crimes and
weapons
they think they're forced to make quick
decisions and of course they're usually
right about that
but they made mistakes that could have
been prevented with relevant information
and of course we've spent two years
where those mistakes have gotten a lot
of publicity
four police officers arrive arrive at a
scene individually
in different cars at different times
now they should become a squad for
police officers that are related by
the commonality of information and the
ease with which they can find out what
others are thinking or look at their
faces and decide if they're sober
uh
it would be good if such a squad can
coordinate share information and reach a
consensus on what the situation is
in such situations there isn't time or
might not seem to be time to do this
consensus building carefully then we
could go over some of the examples where
where where this is is true
i'm i'm sure the other
officers in that recent example or what
recent case that has just been
adjudicated where the woman
shoots the guy she thought she was
holding a taser to
the honors could see she was holding a
taser or she could have too if she
looked
but there wasn't time to really build a
consensus
yeah if she'd been wearing if she'd been
wearing the glasses the glasses could
have told her she's yes she'd been
wearing the glasses
even though she didn't look down and see
whether she had a gun or a tails on her
hand the glasses would know uh
and could communicate that quicker than
the other officers or at least possibly
um well it put big signs up on front in
front of her eyes saying yes but
right so super glasses would have would
have helped her
uh that isn't to say she wasn't a bit
careless confusing a taser for a gun
uh or a gun for taser but
but they would have been helpful
and i'm sure even even a genius like
carl sometimes he's riding along
and if he had super glasses they could
say hey carl
that's not what she said in the last
paragraph until you get super glasses i
have to play that role all the time
there we go that's right
uh so we can imagine the glasses being a
good thing but we can also imagine them
being a bad thing
right
we've learned painfully in recent years
that streamline access to information
is also streamline access to
misinformation
so
as a grouch
i would say carl it's very interesting
that we're going to have these super
glasses
and that big companies like apple are
are involved with it
uh
but
i mean actually who wants them do we
really need them won't they cause more
problems
then then then good and then carl would
say well that's true but you would have
said about that when we replaced
typewriters with computers
and uh you said that about the cell
phones i mean yeah
i'd probably say that about horses and
automobiles
so anyway of course it could be i would
have been right in all those cases
so at any rate slow down with the
glasses
now my second point is uh
well let's go down with the glasses and
we can slow down here
but that doesn't mean the totalitarians
are going to slow down
well
that's true
well on the other hand uh if you have
mainly in mind china
um
china had kind of slowed down about
everything for a century or two after
being a leader of the world for for so
many millennia
and then what got them back in the race
our stupid technology but don't quote me
on that
because i might need a grant from
somebody someday
but as i said
they they
that's right they they adopted the
technology and they've taken it over
privatized it so now that the stuff in
china right
it's much better instead of getting all
this technology if we just said hey
china you're the greatest civilization
ever you've got the greatest language
ever
uh why don't you just focus on
perfecting your language and teaching it
to our
students and we'll take care of the
electronics but i digress i want to get
back to the point that as i said carl is
not an uncritical
computer science ai enthusiast
and he distinguishes two large scenarios
in one super glasses are used to promote
totalitarian practices
and he says that uh the chinese which he
he regards as a
you know pretty totalitarian government
uh has made a huge amount of progress on
the things that are needed for glasses
it may be just to the glasses
on the other hand they could be used to
promote practices of representative
governments
right so i mean
when we started our representative
government we had these things called
the senate and the congress where our
representative met and talked to each
other
but if you watch these meetings now
nobody's there
that's right one person talking away you
know maybe if they all had to wear eye
glass these special glasses they could
stay in their offices and could still
talk to each other and but i'm
digressing uh anyway obviously these
these great pieces of technology could
be used in really good ways and really
bad ways
but
aside from their inevitable use to help
totalitarian practices
that means that they'll get that use
even if they're used widely with
republican than representative practices
there are other problems
and these are connected with problems
that carl has been talking about for
well years
decades
generations
not quite centuries but good parts of
two centuries by now
uh and that is
uh
the glasses get information about the
person who's wearing them
and that person's surroundings
in virtuous position on that person's
head
and and also
one way or another we'll have special
access to that person's thoughts needs
and etc
i at least i assume that works
you know my glasses will know when i
need to go to the bathroom
uh at least they'll know it in a pretty
direct way they may not need they may
also know when carl needs to go to the
bathroom but it won't be in the same way
just so
that's that's an important feature they
could have
uh they will also get all sorts of
information from other sources of
information about other things via the
internet some of this coming originally
from other glasses
so these glasses
uh instead of like my glasses which
whose main virtue is falling off
uh will have all sorts of information
about all things in the world and get
this information different ways it helps
them keep track of its relevance
but the utility of all this will be
limited by the capacity to integrate
information
now carl has emphasized for decades that
traditional and logic
in the computer science and ai based on
them
don't give us all we need for this
uh
this has led to him to criticize some
some saints
of the field of logic and of course
uh
that means a lot of people don't believe
what he say can be right because it
implies that
people like church and girdle have
not gotten everything right
but i was never convinced they had
everything right anyway so i've been
easy to uh
uh convinced of that
well thank you very much john for your
excellent perspective here
we may have one more paragraph one more
paragraph okay so actors and citadels if
you think about them are kind of carl's
effort to develop into cs and ai
some good features of ordinary life
in dealing with information actors are
kind of like people citadels are kind of
like squads or organizations
and if they work
right
they're important parts of real-life
decision-making
and they perform valuable functions that
carl thinks need to be incorporated into
ai and doing things
will allow us to make things more secure
now i'm sure that carl is right about
this
but unlike you guys in the class
i don't really understand it very well
but i recommend to you that you do so
and you'll help keep us free
and maybe get some grants
and make carl more famous than he
already is thank you
thank you very much john that was great
well
yeah if i could just use learn to use my
uh
my own software i might fit into the
world better okay thanks a lot guys well
yeah you need to go out to dinner but
but it's not your software it's created
by all these different companies that
don't talk to each other very well and
don't interface with each other and we
all suffer
well i'll give you an example
so so apple has an apple watch
and so one of my children bought me an
apple watch thinking
i might like it which maybe eventually
it will
but it turns out the apple watches
won't
won't work with my apple phone because
my apple phone is too old it's ancient
probably five years old
so i got so i got a new iphone thing
well you know it's like a new iphone now
now i can link it with my apple watch
but then i was going for a walk-in today
and i wanted to use my earphones
and there's no hole in my apple
iphone to plug in the earphones
and you might say is one of my
grandchildren did well of course not
nobody uses earphones like that anymore
we use earphones that work on bluetooth
and i said well i've got 16 pairs of
earphones that work like this
and now i've got to throw them all away
just because there's not a little hole
drilled in the side of my iphone
thank you apple
if it wasn't for the fact that
i made a fortune investing you on the
stock market i'd really be pissed
all right so long
okay
that's that was great john thank you
very much for your wisdom and your
philosophy and your service for all
these years and particularly in
philosophy talk and csli those are those
are great
all right
thank you for all you've given to the
world and to me in particular
okay well this this has been quite a
gathering uh today
uh
this is the first uh
conversational 380 we've had in quite a
long time
and
[Music]
i think
this is the reason why
many people who
like the class or like the colloquium
idea uh in the
past years is because that a lot of
ideas get tossed out and
run around the block to
see whether they have any real substance
to them
um i'm hoping that we'll have a
continuing uh
ongoing discussion and
continuing exploration of some of the
ideas here carl thank you very much for
your talk
and uh to uh to john i'm glad you got in
because uh your comments were very
useful
and um thank you for your attendance
you